France de Wall. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
[grognement]
Euh je suis un primatologue, éthologue,
hollandais,
américain. J'habite en Amérique,
Atlanta.
Et j'étais entraîné comme un biologue à
Utrecht à Negen à Groningen en Hollanda
que je parte vers l'Amérique.
Je suis spécialisé dans primat j'ai fait
des études quelquefois d'autres espèces
comme les éléphants mais c'est plutôt
les chimpensés, les Benobo et quelques
autres espèces de primate. et j'ai
travaillé beaucoup dans la captivité
et je connais bien sûr tous les travaux
qui sont faits en nature. Au début,
j'étais dans mon travail surtout un
observateur. Je faisais des observations
de comportement de primat tout
[grognement] le temps de de milliers des
heures. Et après, je suis devenu aussi
un expérimentateur quand j'ai fait c des
expériences avec des primates de
comportement, pas pas d'expérience bio
biomédicale ou des choses comme ça, mais
le comportement. Est-ce qu'ils veulent
partager la nourriture ? Est-ce qu'ils
veulent ou comment ils utilisent les
outils des choses comme ça ?
On est très content de vous recevoir ce
soir. On va creuser tout plein de sujets
qui sont aussi connectés avec des sujets
qu'on a pu euh faire sur notre chaîne.
La première question que j'ai envie de
vous poser,
c'est quelle sensation est-ce que vous
pouvez me décrire avec vos mots, votre
perception,
la sensation quand vous vous connectez
avec un animal par le regard. Oh
oui, c'est beaucoup de primatologues qui
travaillent avec des grands singes
surtout.
Ils disent que ils ont, on peut dire
tombé amoureux ou impressionnés par les
animaux surtout quand ils font le
contact des des jeux. Et c'est bizarre
parce qu'on sait pas exactement définir
qu'est-ce que c'est. Il y a plein de des
animaux qui ont les jeux de devant. On
peut regarder par exemple un souè ou un
[grognement] chat. dans les yeux comme
ça, mais on voit pas la même chose que
quand on voit un chien pensé ou un bobo
dans le on voit un personnalité
qui est aussi fort que le que le nôtre.
On voit qu'il y a une volonté derrière
ça
et une détermination qu' on va passer
beaucoup d'autres animaux. Et cette
connexion qui fait qu'on on doute que il
y a une grande différence entre eux et
nous. Normalement, on apprend bien sûr
que nous sommes des hommes, eux, ils
sont des animaux. Mais dans ce contact
là, ça disparaît. En fait, cette
distinction.
Vous venez de dire quelque chose de très
intéressant sur on apprend que eux sont
des animaux.
Oui.
Et que nous, nous sommes des hommes.
Ouais.
Vous comprenez où va aller ma question ?
Pourquoi je vous je vous je vous fais
remarquer que l'apprentissage de l'homme
sur sa perception
de l'autre animal mais une frontière
déjà dans l'apprentissage. Vous qui avez
une expérience
Ouais.
est-ce que vous pensez que pour faire
changer la perception
de l'homme sur son biotop, il faudrait
peut-être changer ça ? Oui, moi je
trouve que la philosophie euh
occidentale,
la religion aussi occidentale, ils sont
liés les deux et ils ont causé beaucoup
de problèmes parce que maintenant on a
la crise de climat, on a les crises de
COVID [grognement] qui tous les deux ils
ont nous montré que on a des animaux sur
une planète des animaux. On peut pas
tout faire ce qu'on veut parce que on
pense qu'on peut faire n'importe quoi
avec les planètes mais ça marche pas
bien et ça ça ça n'affecte boomerang. On
dit en anglais c'est c'est ça ça revient
nous euh de nous mordre dans notre
derrière en fait.
Et euh je trouve que cette distinction
homme animal qui est complètement
artificielle,
qui rien à faire avec la biologie, c'est
sûr, euh était destructif. Et euh
on apprend ça comme enfant, on apprend
nous sommes pas des animaux et je crois
que il y a deux sortes de gens. Il y a
parce que tous les enfants, ils se
sentent proches des animaux. Il ils
dorment avec des animaux, il regarde des
animations, des animaux des qui parlent.
Tous les enfants sont près des animaux.
Il ils se ils se trouvent pas eux-mêmes
supérieurs aux animaux.
C'est un certain âge, je sais pas quand
ça commence, à 12 ans, 13 ans, je sais
pas quoi. Ça commence dans la pub
puberté, je crois, qui qui vont faire
une distinction qui qui vont dire "Moi,
je suis pas un animal." Et je crois
qu'il y a la moitié des des humains qui
prennent ça très sérieux et et on le
rencontre constamment de des gens qui
trouvent que eux ils sont pas des
animaux, ils sont très différents. Et un
autre moitié et moi je suis un de eux
qui et je rencontre beaucoup de gens qui
sont
entourés avec des animaux qui
travaillent avec des animaux qui qui
sentent pas ça forcément. et de sorte
toutes il y a deux deux côtés de cette
équation et en France bien sûr avec les
les traditions cartésienne
c'est c'est ça c'était très fort cette
idée que nous on a un esprit les animaux
malheureusement ils ont rien mais cette
idée é là
on va parler d'intelligence
collaborative
chez les grands singes est-ce que vous
pouvez me donner quelques exemples
d'intelligence collaborative, de
collaboration pour mieux avancer. Et
ensuite, j'aimerais qu'on parle des
notions de mal alpha, de femelle alpha,
de couple alpha.
Ouais.
La coopération est très développée chez
beaucoup animaux. C'est dommage que on
popularise le le darwinisme avec le le
struggle for life euh avec un terme qui
veut dire de conflit comme s'il y a
toujours de conflits. Il y a beaucoup
animaux et je parle même pas des
insectes, les les fourmis, les
thermites, les abeilles, il y a mais il
y a beaucoup d'autres aliments aussi qui
qui sont très collaborateurs et comme
les éléphants, le dauphin, le loup, le
le primat, beaucoup de primates qui
survivent par coopération.
Et euh
le cas le plus développé, c'est
peut-être par exemple le chimposé qui
chasse qui qui chasse des petits singes
pour la viande
pour la viande et ils sont très
collaborateurs, ils ont des visions de
comportement
mais il y a aussi par exemple Orcas qui
orc
des orcs oui
qui sont extrêmement coopératifs. Ils
font des choses que nous on comprend pas
tellement. par exemple euh s'il y a un
comment dire un un seal euh c'est quoi
un f sur sur le
sur sur un ice float hein sur le glace
un bout de glace
qui est là-dessus et quelquefois et et
c'est filmé maintenant il y a des des
vidéos de ça on voit cinq hous qui se
mettent l'un après avec l'autre et ils
font un vague
ils bougent et ils font un grand vague.
qui mettent le f dans le mer et comme ça
ils les prennent. Et on sait pas comment
ils peuvent coordiner ça si précisément
parce que ils sont extrêmement coordinés
pendant qu'ils les font et on sait pas
qui donne le signal de le faire et tout
ça et euh il y a coopération énorme.
Alors la coopération est très
développée. C'est quelquefois
extrêmement intelligent entre les
individus. quelquefois c'est plus
automatisé je crois comme si le fourmi
peut-être mais c'est très développé dans
les animaux. Oui.
Revenons à cette notion de couple alpha,
de mâle alpha, de femelle alpha.
Qu'est-ce qui fait
un bon couple alpha ? C'est
transmettre son patrimoine génétique en
priorité parce que c'est les plus forts,
les mieux adaptés. Est-ce que c'est
parce que c'est aussi les plus
intelligents ? Est-ce que c'est ceux qui
font mieux vivre le groupe ?
Est-ce que c'est une un respect par la
force et la violence
ou est-ce que c'est autre chose ?
Oui, le le terme alpha ça vient de de la
recherche sur le loup. Ça commencé avec
ça. Et en général, on utilise le terme
alpha pour le le l'individu de de plus
haut rang
dans une hiérarchie.
Ça peut être un mâle chez le mâle, un
femelle chez le femelle parce que en
général ils sont divisés entre mâle et
femelle et parce que la plupart des
compétitions dans un groupe c'est entre
les individus du même sexe.
Entre les deux sexes, il y a pas
tellement de compétitions. C'est entre
les mâles et entre les femelles qu'on
trouve beaucoup de compétitions.
Alors le mal alpha c'est le mal plus de
plus haut status dans dans le groupe et
ils ont des personnalités qui sont très
variables. C'est un peu comme les hommes
politiques. Oui. Ils peuvent être très
gentils et très constructifs et et il
protège parce que souvent ils protègent
de underdog comment dire les les
individus qui qui ont des problèmes et
il ils arrêtent les les bagarres dans le
groupe il gardent les paix. Il y a des
mals comme ça et euh ça c'est des mals
alpha mais il y a aussi des mals
quelquefois qui sont des tyrants qui qui
sont des dictateurs et qui sont pas si
constructifs et et souvent le groupe
n'aime pas ce genre de mal et essaie de
l'enlever de de sa position.
Chez les femelles, c'est un peu
différent parce que la hiérarchie de
femelle est souvent basée sur la
personnalité et l'âge. C'est diffend
comme chez le mal.
Ça veut dire que un femelle quelquefois
par la chien pensée peut être alpha
pendant 40 ans comme j'ai décrit mama le
chien passé alpha de grand colonie qui
était alphabetant 40 ans. Elle elle
pouvait presque plus marcher. Elle était
presque aveugle à la fin. Elle elle
était elle avait 60 ans à la fin. Euh
mais elle est encore [grognement]
femelle alpha parce que les femelles euh
être plus vieil c'est c'est positif.
C'est c'est ça aide. C'est le mal un mal
de ce qui peut plus marcher. Il n'est
plus alpha. Il est fini par d'autres il
est enlevé de sa position par d'autres
mal. Alors les positions sont très
différentes
mais les gens souvent ils sont très
préoccupés par le force physique. Ils
pensent que c'est le mal le plus fort
qui est alpha ou le femelle le plus fort
qui est alpha. C'est pas forcément ça
euh le mal alpha. chez le ch passé par
exemple peut être un petit mal, il peut
être plus petit que le reste mais il a
les il est diplomatique, il a des amis,
il fait des épouillages, il partage la
nourriture avec d'autres, il a fait des
amis ou peut-être les femelles le
soutiennent et comme ça il devient le
mâle alpha et c'est quelque fois le mâle
le plus petit qui est comme ça. Et chez
les femelles aussi, même si les femelles
peuvent pas physiquement dominer un
mâle, ça veut pas dire qu'ils ont pas
plus de pouvoir. Ils peuvent avoir plus
de pouvoir dans le groupe parce qu'ils
ont plus de connexion dans le groupe.
C'est c'est tout un jeu politique et les
gens sont souvent
euh euh comment dire étonnés par ça.
Mais je trouve ça bizarre parce que nous
dans notre société on on réagit pas
comme ça. Moi je veux savoir ici à Paris
dans une un magasin, je je entré, je
veux voir le boss, le manager. Euh je
regarde pas le plus grand mec qui est
dans le dans l'endroit pour pour penser
en pensant que ça c'est le le le boss de
duendroit.
Alors nous on a l'habitude de de diviser
entre force physique et la dominance et
et le pouvoir surtout et si d'autres
d'autres primates ça ça marche
exactement pareil. Alors par exemple si
le benobu les femelles sont dominants.
Les femelles sont plus petits que le
mâle. Alors physiquement une femelle
peut pas dominer mâle mais les femelles
sont souvent ensemble.
et ensemble ils peuvent dominer à mal
alors et ils font ça. H
quel regard vous portez sur notre
société occidentale
au 21e siècle en tant qu' éthologue et
en tant que primatologue ? Est-ce que
vous pensez
qu'on est des grands primates ayant des
troubles psychologiques
et névrotiques et qu'on n'est plus
capable d'avoir un réflexe de Laurence ?
pour apaiser une situation.
Est-ce que vous pensez que nous sommes
condamnés en tant qu'espèce car nous ne
sommes plus capables de nous apaiser ?
Vous parliez vous avez étudié les
macaques.
H
les macaques passent 50 % de leur
journée à se taper dessus et 50 % de
leur journée à avoir des comportements
de réconciliation, de socialisation,
d'échange.
Quel regard vous portez sur notre
société ? C'est c'est pas 50 % 50 %
c'est
plutôt euh peut-être 5 % du temps ils
ont bagar
ils ont le conflit
et le plupart du temps ils sont en train
de jouer de faire des épouillages de
dormir ensemble
de de des relations sexuelles. Non non
le quand moi j'étais étudiante j'ai
euh Conrad Law était très important à
l'époque. Est-ce que vous pouvez
rappeler ce que c'est un réflexe de
Lawrence ?
Euh Lawrence
un comment dire euh fixed action
patterns. C'est ça le mot qui utilisait.
C'était des choses dans des animaux qui
qui ont l'air préprogrammé parce que
chaque membre de l'espèce a la même
réaction à certaines situations.
Et fixed action pattern pour pour
l'homme, une chose typique c'est
l'expression faciale. C'est par exemple
rire. rire ou sourire ou pleurer, ça
c'est un fixed action pattern parce que
chez tous les hommes dans le monde,
c'est la même sorte réaction dans le
visage.
Alors Laurence avait cette idée mais il
avait écrit un livre sur l'agression, ça
s'appelle on agression en anglais et euh
c'était ça va beaucoup d'influence et
quand moi j'ai été étudiant, tout le
monde voulait faire des études
d'agression chez les animaux.
toutes toutes sortes d'animaux mais
surtout des primates, des chiens, des
rats, des animaux comme ça. Et parce que
Laurence avait dit qu'il y a un instinct
agressif chez les animaux et c'est
pareil que chez l'homme et puisque lui
il était austrien, comment dire
autrichien.
Autrichien,
il avait servi dans la guerre, pas dans
la guerre,
du mauvais côté.
Du mauvais côté.
Et c'est pour ça que les gens étaient
pas si contents que lui il disait il y a
un instinct agressif, on peut rien
faire. C'est un peu une excuse on
trouvait. Alors Laurence n'est pas très
populaire pour cette raison, mais il
avait beaucoup d'influence avec son
livre et moi je faisais des études
d'agression chez les cheens chez
d'autres espèces et ça que je trouve le
plus intéressant que après qu'il y avait
un conflit entre eux, il y a un
réconciliation. Souvent les ch passés
ils viennent ensemble, ils s'embrassent,
ils se euh ils se donnent des baisés et
après ils font l'époyage chez les
benobos sexuel, ils ont un contact
sexuel après un conflit et moi j'étais
plus intéressé dans ça que dans le
conflit eux-mêmes qui qui sont assez
rares et tout le monde sait qu' ils
arrivent et moi j'étais plus intéressé
dans la relation sociale qu'ils avaient
et qu'est-ce qu'ils font avec. Alors,
c'était un peu un message mon travail
mon travail quand j'étais jeune, un
message contre Lawrence parce que je
voyais à l'autre côté de de toute cette
équation. Oui.
Quel regard vous portez sur notre
société
où le monde est en train de rentrer en
guerre ?
Est-ce que c'est parce que on a
désappris à se réconcilier ?
Quel regard vous portez sur ça La la
guerre une chose que
les chimpanzés se font la guerre
entre groupe entre les groupe des chiens
passensés les mals sont extrêmement
agressifs.
Quel est l'objectif ?
Et il se tue entre eux et c'est tout
pour le territoire. Sur le territoire il
y a le le les arbres avec le fruit il y
a des femelles dans le territoire et
c'est pour ça qu'il se tuent entre eux.
Lesobres font font pas du tout ça. Ben
se mélangent entre groupes. Ils sont pas
hostiles.
On les appelle syophil philic. les
symposi sont synophobiques et les sont
synophiliques et euh
oui le la guerre chez l'homme les choses
pour par exemple mon dernier livre
c'était sur les genres et euh c'est vrai
que les hommes ils sont un position
privilégiée dans notre société
mais penant la guerre les hommes, ils
ont pas une position privilégiée. On
voit ça maintenant. On voit que les
femmes et les enfants, ils peuvent
quitter le pays de Ukraine. Les hommes,
ils peuvent pas. Et les hommes
ukrainiens qui retournent à leur pays,
ils peuvent plus sortir parce qu'ils
sont recrutés dans l'armée. Et euh moi,
je suis né juste après la guerre
mondiale et je sais que si moi je serais
né euh 50 ans plus tôt, sans doute je
serai soldier dans une armée et
peut-être tué.
Alors pendant la guerre, les les jeunes
hommes surtout ils ont pas de position
privilégiée dans le monde. Mais pendant
la paix, on a eu une paix de 60 ans 70
ans maintenant.
Pax américana.
Oui, on a eu une paix.
Oui, c'est aussi le le l'Union Européen
qui a fait ça. C'est EU qui a fait ça.
On a eu une paix très longue et on a
oublié le la situation pour les jeunes
hommes pendant la guerre et on a ça
exposé je crois les privilèges de
l'homme plus que dans la société. Et
c'est pour ça qu'on ess toute cette
discussion sur le les genre et la
position de l'homme et femme.
Partiellement un résultat de ça et
partiellement un résultat de pilule qui
est venu dans les années 60.
Contraception.
La contraception qui a changé toute la
discussion sur le le famille était très
grand. Moi, je suis d'une grande famille
et la famille était très grand à
l'époque. H
Est-ce que vous voyez des similitudes
entre les conflits qu'on les macac et
les chimpanzés et les conflits que nous
nous pouvons avoir à l'égard d'autres
pays ? Est-ce que c'est pour le
territoire,
pour la nourriture et les femmes ?
Ouais. Je trouve la guerre humain,
c'est c'est assez dur de comparer ça
avec les les action polici pensé ou
d'autres espèces.
Euh les gens essayé ça, mais nos
sociétés sont si grands et c'est si
massifs. On a des millions de gens qui
sont organisés, une armée, une
organisation de millions de de jeunes
hommes.
Euh c'est c'est pas exactement pareil.
Mais derrière ça, il y a sans doute un
un un côté
territorialité d'un tout côté de comme
le le Russes maintenant, ils veulent
avoir un territoire plus grand parce qu'
ils peuvent pas accepter que l'Ukraine
est là est devenue indépendante d'eux.
Alors, ils acceptent pas ça. Alors, il y
a cette côté territorial,
mais
le comment dire de scale
comment direchelle
l'échelle de de le les taille de conflit
est tellement différent entre ce qui se
passe là et qui se passe entre les
primates que la comparaison est très
problématique je trouve. Si je vous dis
homo omini loupous est,
ça vous fait penser à quoi ?
Je trouve c'est très dommage cette
expression. Man is a wolf to man.
L'homme est un loup pour l'homme.
Oui. Ouai. Je trouve ça dommage parce
que d'abord c'est pas vrai pour le loup.
Ça fait comme les loups. Ils sont des
bêtes méchants. Ils peuvent être
méchants mais ils sont pas toujours
méchants. Ils sont très coopératifs en
fait comme société.
Et ça donne l'impression aussi que c'est
très hobbéien Thomas Hobbes.
C'est l'idée que l'homme par nature est
compétitif et euh méchant et nasty et
moi je crois que l'homme est un espèce
extrêmement coopératif.
Euh on peut être comme ça, c'est c'est
vrai. Euh on on a le potentiel d'être
méchant et nasti mais euh de de de
comment dire de summarize, comment dire
de
résumer
résumer notre espèce dans cette
phrase-là, je trouve très
euh euh très problématique parce que il
y a beaucoup d'autres choses, beaucoup
d'autres aspects de comportement chez
nous. Il faut expliquer aussi pourquoi
quand les loups se battent, ils évitent
trop sous ils évitent le maximum de
verser trop le sang pour éviter
Oui.
d'avoir un handicapé dans le groupe pour
aller chercher.
Oui, un loup bien sûr c'est un
prédateur. Bien sûr quand il attaque un
autre espèce
il il n'est pas gentil, il va le tuer.
Ça c'est le but.
C'est subjectif le mot gentil. Non.
Oui oui, on on il faut même pas parler
comme ça de de de parce qu' il mangent
il mange comme ça. Euh entre eux
les conflits sont pas si durs que les
gens pensent. Et ça arrive que le loup
se tue entre eux. Ça arrive aussi que
les chens pensés se tuent eux. Mais ça
c'est général pas le but. Et c'est c'est
en fait très rare que ça arrive.
Jane Goud
a fait des déclarations aujourd'hui en
disant que l'homme est en train de se
rapprocher du point de non retour.
Ouais, elle a raison je crois.
Pourquoi ?
Dans dans le les choses climatiques, je
crois. Et aussi les le le extermin
extermination des espèces extinction des
espèces. On oui, on
on est dans une situation où c'est
bizarre, nous on a un espèce qui qui
peut qui peut penser en avance. On a
cette capacité de penser en avance. On
sait déjà depuis 30 ans ou 40 ans que le
climat va pas bien, que l'écologie va
pas bien.
On sait ça mais on fait pas grand-chose.
Et euh c'est dommage qu'on a cette
capacité de penser en avance et on
l'utilise pas. Et c'est c'est pour ça
qu'elle dit ça parce que on est dans une
situation où ça devient très dur de
retourner je crois.
Est-ce que vous connaissez Coco le gori
qui parle ? H
le langage des signes.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Ah, j'ai j'ai des problèmes avec ce ces
études là. Il y a deux problèmes.
D'abord, c'est une approche extrêmement
anthropocentrique
de de prendre notre capacité humain qui
est très spécial, le langage
et le pousser ça vers les grands singes
et voir qu'est-ce qu'ils font avec.
et on on leur apprend certaines choses.
On a appris maintenant que la plupart
des de des grands singes qui apprennent
le langage,
ils sont pas ils sont peut-être à le
niveau d'un enfant de 2 ans et c'est pas
si impressionnant. On peut pas faire une
discussion avec eux sur un sujet
abstrait. On peut on peut leur demander
de chercher quelque chose dans une autre
chambre, mais on peut pas euh avoir une
discussion philosophique avec eux.
Est-ce qu'on peut leur demander s'ils
sont tristes ?
Ça, on peut demander sur les émotions,
on peut faire des questions. Oui. Ou sur
les situations autour de eux, mais c'est
très limité
ça. D'abord, d'abord le problème c'est
que on
c'est entreprene centrique. au lieu de
faire des études de communication de
gorille ou de du sien pensé naturel et
voir qu'est-ce qu' ils se disent entre
eux, on on a leur a forcé de prendre
notre système de communication et et
parce qu'on est impressionné par notre
propre système. Ça c'est un problème. Le
deuxième problème, c'est les études de
coco spécifiquement
sont pas bien faits. Il y a d'autres
études avec d'autres là par exemple Wasu
de Simpan ou Kanzi de Benobo euh qui
sont bien contrôlés et ils sont vidéos
et dans l'ordinateur et on sait toutes
les l'histoire de tout ce qu'ils ont
appris et on peut comparer ce qu'ils
disent maintenant avec ce qu'ils ont dit
il y a 10 ans. avec Coco, c'est pas bien
fait et il y a beaucoup de plaines dans
le les journaux scientifiques qui
parlent de capacité de langage chez les
chez les singes que les études de coco
sont pas si bien faits que ceux de
d'autres espèces. Oui,
on a vu des goris dépressifs dans des
eaux souvent d'ailleurs. Hm
hm.
Et récemment parce que Ingori les les
gens qui visitaient ce ce zo leur
montraient le téléphone portable.
Ouais, j'ai entendu de ces cas là. Oui.
Alors, c'est parce que c'est les
conditions de détention qui sont pas
bonnes pour le gori.
Il y a souvent dans les eau, il y a des
gens qui essayent de développer relation
avec un certain animal. On avait on
avait le même cas en Hollande à un
certain moment avec un un gor mal qui
est échappé.
Il a pris un un un une femme
un un femelle humain. [grognement] Il a
pris et essayé de le enlever et mettre
dans son enclos.
Et euh c'est parce que elle visitait
chaque jour chaque jour elle faisait le
contact avec lui et un certain moment et
il a peut-être pensé elle me veut alors
je le veux opportunité.
Je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'il il a pensé
mais
on il faut éviter ce genre de choses et
les euh dans ce cas là avec le le le
gori et le le téléphone qu'il a regardé
le petit film je crois euh
ça devient trop à un certain moment il y
a trop de relations humain gorill et lui
il a oublié qu'il il était aussi il
faisait aussi partie d'un groupe de
gorill et il il était plus orienté faire
les gens et c'est toujours un danger
C'est surtout un danger avec des des
singes qui sont élevés par les humains
parce que ils sont très human oriented
plus que plus que orientés vers leur
propre espèce.
Ils se font rejetés par le groupe.
Ça peut arriver. Oui, c'est pour ça que
à à Arnemzo où j'étais quand j'étais
plus jeune,
on avait un bébé qui qui est qui qui
était rejeté par la mère qu'on qu'on
voulait don vous l' élever mais au lieu
de nous élever le bébé ch pensé avec un
une bouteille et du lait, on a appris à
un femelle chimpensé de élever le bébé.
On a on a appris de de comment donner la
bouteille au bébé.
Comment ça se passe ? Vous mettez vous
déguisez en chimpanzé ?
Non non non. Je suis pas déguisé non de
tout. J'avais les bébés chimpanés avec
moi. Euh, j'ai donne la bouteille. La
femelle chimpané était dans un endroit
derrière des grillage. Je donne
bouteille à elle et je je lui montre le
bébé et j'explique, je prends sa main et
j'explique comment faire ça. Et après un
certain temps, parce que c'est vraiment
pas dur pour ma passensé de faire ça,
après un certain temps, elle a compris
que c'est c'est ça que je voulais faire
avec le bébés.
Le plus dur en fait dans dans cette
expérience là, c'était que elle voulait
boire le le lait elle-même.
Il fallait d'abord apprendre que c'était
pas pour elle, c'était pour le bébé. Et
on a pris ça et j'ai fait ça pendant je
crois 3 semaines 4 semaines comme ça et
un certain moment j'ai donné le bébé à
cette femelle
et
d'une façon anxieuse, c'est pas son
bébé, qu'est-ce qu'elle va en faire ?
Oui. Euh ça c'était un risque bien sûr
parce que je l'ai mis dans son cage. Euh
le elle vivit dans un grand groupe de 25
j' pensé mais l'expérience était faite
dans une un petit cage. Alors j'ai je lu
donné le bébé, elle voulait pas accepter
le bébé.
Elle euh venue vers moi et le le
ketcher, comment dire ?
Soignant. Le soignant soignant. Euh ça
c'est une femme, les deux de nous et
elle venait vers nous et euh c'était
comme si elle demandait est-ce qu'elle
peut prendre le bébé parce que le bébé
est à nous. Et normalement entre passé,
c'est pas normal que tu prends le bébé
de quelqu'un d'autre sans demander ou
sans être accepté. Alors euh nous on a
dit prends-le, prends-le, prends-le. Et
euh après un certain moment, je crois
c'était au moins 15 minutes. Après 15
minutes, elle a pris le bébé sur elle et
dès ce moment le bébé n'a plus quitté
cette femelle. C'est resté sur elle tout
le temps, 100 % du temps. Et là bien sûr
le le problème c'est est-ce qu'elle veut
elle veut encore donner la bouteille
maintenant parce que le bébé était
dépend elle pouvait pas nourrir le bébé
autrement.
Et là euh oui, on a réussi ça. Elle a
élevé cette bébé qui qui était adopté et
après elle a élevé ses propres enfants
aussi avec la bouteille. On avait choisi
cette femelle parce que elle était très
maternelle mais elle était jamais
capable de d'élever ses propres enfants
parce qu'elle avait pas assez de lait.
On c'est pour ça qu'on l'a choisi. Et
après et et ça c'est ça c'est
intéressant parce que elle est toujours
restée extrêmement attachée à moi.
Elle était mort il y a peut-être 10 ans.
Chaque fois que je visitais la Hollande
visitais le chensé
et inclusif cette femelle
était c'était comme si j'étais la
famille. Elle était toujours euh
extrêmement, comment dire euh grateful
euh
euh grateful euh euh Ah je ça c'est
reconnaissante. Merci.
reconnaissante oui. Alors moi je je
faisais partie de sa famille, c'était
clair. Et et c'est c'est parce que j'ai
fait possible pour elle d'avoir des
enfants parce que autrement elle pouvait
pas.
Ça c'est pas une interprétation de votre
part.
Absolument. Ça c'est une interprétation.
Oui, c'est c'est pas très scientifique
de dire ça, mais c'était comme ça. Oui,
elle était extrêmement comme ça. Un peu
comme on peut voir aussi avec des des
chiens ou des chats qu'on adopte dans de
la rue. Il y a quelquefois un chien qui
est abandonné qui que nous on prend dans
la maison. Euh, on peut voir que ils ont
une attitude un peu différente d'autres
chiens.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'ils ont connu des
conditions difficiles.
Ils ont connu un vie très difficile et
toi tu es celui-ci qui aidé de d'avoir
une autre vie qui a fait ça possible.
Nous on avait un chat qu'on avait adopté
un un chat mal un gros chat qui euh qui
était adopté par nous et qui était
complètement abandonné. Il était
complètement plein de puces et tout
quand on l'a pris. Et toute sa vie,
au contraire de toutes les autres chat
qu'on a eu, toute sa vie, il a ronroné
quand tu vas à la nourriture, tu montres
la nourriture et ron ron. C'est comme
comme si pour lui c'était quelque chose
de extraordinaire que ça existait, qu'il
pouvait avoir la nourriture de
quelqu'un. Oui.
Vous apprenez euh
des choses au champanzés ? Hm hm.
Les chimpanzés, ils vous apprennent quoi
? Qu'est-ce que vous avez appris au
contact des chimposés ? Qu'est-ce que
vous avez Qu'est-ce que les chimpanzés
vous ont enseigné mis à part leur
comportement ?
Qu'est-ce que vous avez pu découvrir à
leur contact ? Est-ce qu'ils vous ont
chuchoté à l'oreille ? Est-ce qu'ils
vous ont
étonné ? Est-ce qu'ils vous ont secoué ?
Ils m'ont souvent étonné
mais je pense que le le plus bazar c'est
que
je me réalise que
mais peut-être cette attitude existait
déjà avant que j'ai rencontré les gens
pensés que j'ai que je suis un animal
que moi je vois pas personnellement que
psychologiquement je suis très différent
d'un champ pensé je pense que dans dans
les émotions sociaux les psychologies
socio émotionnel,
je suis un grand singe. Et dans ma
écriture euh mon écriture, j'essaie de
convaincre d'autres gens que on est des
grands singes en fait psychologiquement
on on est différent dans le sens de
capacité intellectuelle ou le capacité
de langage ou des capacités de
technologie. peut-être même la façon
qu'on réagit de des situations sociales
n'est pas très différent. C'est c'est
extrêmement similaire, je trouve.
Et euh ça c'est peut-être les choses de
base qui les que les chiens possib
euh quand je commençais mes études des
gens ils avaient assez de des de des de
des des des opinions assez simples sur
comment les les animaux étaient des des
machines instinct instinct en fait
des choses primitives.
Oui. chose extrêmement simple et cette
cette attitude dans les éthologies
c'était très prominent. On parle
beaucoup de instinct
et dans la psychologie on parle beaucoup
de conditioning, comment dire
apprentissage je crois
le conditionnement.
Oui, conditionnement.
Et toutes ces deux-là euh l'instin et le
conditionnement sont des choses
extrêmement simples qui sont pareils
pour toutes les espèces et euh on avait
pas d'attention pour le la variabilité
individuelle, euh le comportement
sophistiqué,
le le le conscience, les émotions, le
planifier euh il y a toutes sortes de
choses cognitives que les les animaux
font qu' qu'on regarda pas à l'époque. H
pourquoi ? parce que c'était le milieu
socioculturel qui influençait les
primatologues et les ethnologues.
Oui, je pense que
c'était l'air du temps.
C'était pas acceptable même que mon
professeur qui faisait des études de des
expressions faciales le primat et les
gens,
il il n'avait pas le droit de parler des
émotions sur les pensées. Il pouvait
parler des des émotions humaines.
C'était possible mais pas des animaux.
Et maintenant, heureusement, on a changé
cette attitude là. Mais à l'époque,
tout ce qui était à l'intérieur de
l'animal, la conscience, les émotions,
c'était pas
Qu'est-ce que vous appelez conscience ?
La conscience de soi, la conscience des
autres.
Ouais, c'est c'est très dur à définir la
conscience. Il y a il y a toute en
académie, il y a toutes les conférences
qui sont sur le sujet de conscience.
Mais personne sait exactement qu'est-ce
que c'est. C'est bizarre comme
situation. On n jamais c cette
situation. On a ça. Et moi j'ai dit
toujours, mais c'est un peu méchant de
dire ça. C'est tu me dis qu'est-ce que
les consciences et moi je te dis que
l'éléphant là ou non. Et j'ai jamais
réponse à ça parce que c'est très dur à
définir. Mais il y a une chose que je
peux dire sur la conscience.
Il y a certaines choses
que nous on peut pas faire sans être
conscient. Par exemple, si tu veux faire
un un petite fête pour tes amis demain
et il faut que tu es conscient de quelle
musique tu vas avoir, combien tu vas
avoir boire, qui tu vas inviter, à
quelle heure ça commence et ça prend
certaine conscience. Autrement, tu peux
pas planifier un petit fait pour tes
amis.
Et on sait de d'expérience qu'on fait
que certainement les grands singes mais
aussi certains autres animaux, ils
peuvent planifier dans le futur. On fait
des expériences là-dessus. On donne par
exemple des utiles qui peuvent pas tout
utiliser tout de suite mais que qui
peuvent seulement utiliser quelques
heures plus tard ou quelque fois le
lendemain.
Des outils.
Oui, des outils. Oui,
on fait des expériences sur le
planification des animaux et dans la
nature aussi, on voit des siens passés
par exemple qui prennent des outils
prennent par exemple grassems, comment
dire le
des brindilles
ou
des brins d'herbes.
Oui. Ils prennent ça, ils mettent ça
dans leur bouche, ils marchent
2 3 km avec ça et et là ils se trouvent
dans le dans la thermite
et bien sûr ils ont su pendant qu' il
ramassaient les outils que ils allaient
faire ça. Et on a des
beaucoup d'évidence maintenant de de
planification par des animaux.
Ça veut dire si nous on peut pas faire
ce genre de choses sans être conscient
de situation,
c'est très dur à argumenter que les
animaux peuvent faire ça sans
conscience. Alors c'est pour ça que la
plupart de nous, on trouve que le le mot
conscience, même si c'est pas très bien
défini, s'applique aussi aux animaux.
Alors, si ça s'applique aux animaux,
[raclement de gorge]
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des eaux ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
expériences
sur les macaques avec Elon Musk et
Neuralink ?
Si c'est un animal
Musk, il a fait des expériences
sur l'implantation de puce.
Ah oui, je crois que j'ai vu ça. Oui,
si c'est quelque si j'allais dire
quelque chose mais est-ce qu'on peut
dire quelqu'un pour un animal ?
Il y a deux choses, ce sont des choses
pour moi différentes. Les eaux, tu
parles des eaux et les expériences.
Les eau et il a de bonnes eaux et de
mauvais eau. Je
c'est quoi un bon zoau ?
Un bon zoau qui donne l'espace aux
animaux, qui la garde dans une un
contexte social qui est euh qui qui
s'applique au aux espèces qu'ils ont.
Alors alors par exemple les pensé, ils
doivent être dans un groupe, pas un
petit groupe mais un assez grand groupe
euh avec beaucoup d'espace.
Euh moi je crois que les autres sont
nécessaires parce que les gens
maintenant on est très urbanisé, il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont moins de
contact avec la nature. Ils savent rien
de la nature.
Et les eaux par exemple en Amérique,
les eaux qu'on a, ils ont 100 175
millions
de visiteurs par an.
Beaucoup de gens visitent les eau et
c'est comme ça au moins, je sais que la
plupart du temps, ils sont là pour leur
leurs petits enfants et tout ça, mais
ils aussi ils apprennent des choses dans
le même contexte. Les sont importants
pour qu'on apprend des choses sur les
animaux et en plus euh les animaux dans
la nature, ils ont beaucoup de
problèmes. Par exemple, les orangutang
maintenant on sait que dans les derniers
20 ans, 100000 orangzout ont disparu.
Alors si moi je serais un orangutang, je
peut-être je préfère être dans un bon
zoau que être à Borneo parce que c'est
c'est une situation extrême dure et
extrêmement dangereux pour mon espèce.
Alors les eaux, je crois, moi je je suis
fan des eaux. Moi je trouve que les eau,
on a besoin de ça. Les expériences avec
des animaux là, ça dépend comment urgent
la situation est.
Euh par exemple le le vaccin contre les
ébola, le vaccin contre COVID aussi est
testé sur les primat et heureusement pas
beaucoup de primat parce qu'autrefois le
polio, le vaccin de polio, ça a coûté
100000 macaques.
Un génocide
hein.
Un génocide. Oui, ça c'est énorme. C'est
énorme. Ça c'était complètement
développé sur les primates. Maintenant,
les primates sont plutôt utilisés pour
tester. Alors, c'est un nombre beaucoup
plus réduit.
Alors certaines situations, je crois que
on a besoin des animaux pour les
expérimentations, mais il y a d'autres
expériences que peut-être on peut on n
pas besoin qui qui sont pas urgents pour
résoudre certaines situations qui c'est
plutôt la curiosité et moi je suis pas
très pour euh les expériences
neurocientifiques sur les primates qui
sont comme ça et j'espère que dans le
futur On on va vers un contexte
d'expérimentation non invasive. Comment
dire ça en français ?
Pas invasif.
Oui. Comment on fait avec les gens ?
Moi, je peux faire un neurosign sur toi.
On le met dans un scanner. Euh on on te
demande pas de bouger. Euh on te demande
des questions et comme ça je peux avoir
des informations. Qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans tes cerveaux ? Et j'espère que dans
le futur, ça sera le futur peut-être
aussi de de neuroc sur les sur les
primates, mais on n'est pas encore là
clairement. Une question qui n'a rien à
voir, mais peut-être un peu. On voit
souvent les gorilles,
excusez-moi pour le terme, et le lancer
sur le public. C'est parce que ils sont
pas à l'aise. Ils aiment pas les
contacts directement dans les yeux, ils
en ont assez de voir une foule devant
chez eux.
Ouais.
Pourquoi ils font ça ? Ça peut arriver
si les gorilles sont trop près du public
ou le public trop près de eux
du tout
euh il y a que qu'ils ont pas d'espace
de se isoler parce que dans les eaux
dans les bonnes eaux je dirais euh les
les gorill ils ont un enclos où ils
peuvent se cacher s'ils veulent et il
faut toujours donner les animaux parce
que les eau il y a tellement milliers de
gens et ils font beaucoup de bruit
[grognement] et écrit tout le temps Il
faut donner des animaux un échappe
échappatoire.
Oui. Et bonzo fait ça. Il a des enclos
où où les animaux sont libres
d'interacter avec le public ou pas s'ils
veulent pas. Oui.
Le cirque
quand on voit euh pour vous le cirque
c'est quoi ? Euh non, quand j'étais
enfant, j'étais j'adorais les cirques
parce que j'adorais les animaux, je
crois. Mais je non, je veux plus de
cirque. Je c'est ça plus c'est surtout
par exemple les éléphants maintenant
bien sûr presque tous les éléphants sont
enlevés de circ euh de Ringling Brothers
euh en Amérique, ils avaient plein
d'éléphants qui étaient transportés dans
des trains euh dans le climat très
froid.
Maintenant, ils sont tous à Floride dans
de grands espaces et ils sont plus dans
le cirque
avec les vieux.
Oui. Oui. Avec d'autres vieux humains.
Oui.
Pourquoi vous aimez les animaux ?
Pourquoi quand vous étiez jeune hm
hm
enfant vous aimiez les animaux ?
Ça, je sais pas. Ça, il y a pas de de
réponse à cette question. Il y a
certains enfants qui adorent les animaux
et il y a d'autres enfants qui qui ont
rien avec des animaux. Je sais pas
qu'est-ce que c'est. Vous aviez des
problèmes pour communiquer avec vos
congénères
euh avec des des humains ?
Non, je je moi je je sais qu'il y a
certains gens qui qui peuvent seulement
compliquer avec des animaux et pas très
bien avec de d'autres gens, mais j'ai
pas cette problème là. Non.
Pourquoi vous avez choisi de faire
primatologue
et pourquoi vous avez choisi l'étologie
? Est-ce que c'est l'étéologie qui vous
a choisi ?
J'ai au début je savais pas euh qu'il y
avait un un des études de comportements
des animaux.
Alors au début, j'étais étudiant en
biologie en biologie et je voyais
seulement des animaux morts. Fall le
couper, faire anatomie. Euh et ça
m'intéressait pas du tout des animaux
morts. Et euh je suis allé de Nére
université Chroning où il faisait des
étologie, il faisait des comportements
animals.
Et moi j'étais j'étais ravi que ça
existait, qu'il y avait une façon de
faire la recherche sur le comportement
et une des plus fameuses
étologues était Tenbergens qui est
hollandais.
Euh Tenberg Lawrence son sont le
fondateur de
Tenberg avait beaucoup d'influence dans
Groninga et que comme ça j'ai je suis
dans la tradition de Tinbergin
et euh
le primat ça c'est devenu beaucoup plus
tard. Moi j'ai j'ai été intéressé dans
toutes sortes d'animaux en fait. Je suis
je suis très intéressé dans le poisson.
J'ai j'ai beaucoup de poissons à la
maison, mes propres poissons et euh
je pense que le le la primatologie c'est
un sorte accident. Je suis tombé
accidentiellement dans la primatologie
et j'avais de hasard.
Oui. Oui. Ouais. Et euh je suis très
content parce que pour les comparaisons
avec l'homme, les primates sont bien sûr
très spécial parce que nous nous sommes
des primates mais euh ça c'est
secondaire. Euh le premier soir c'est de
travailler avec des animaux vivants et
et et voir leur comportement.
Est-ce que les animaux ont une
conscience
de la mort ? Est-ce que ils anticipent
la mort ? Est-ce qu'ils ressentent
l'affinitude de la vie ou est-ce que mes
questions sont trop anthropomorphiques
dans leur par rapport à leur perception
?
Non, c'est une bonne question.
Il y a beaucoup animaux que je crois il
ils connaissent les la mort des autres.
Alors si euh un chien pensé meurt par
exemple,
toutes les autres chiens pensés adultes,
ils sont très ils deviennent très
tranquilles. Ils font ils font plus de
bruit. Normalement, ils sont
ils font plus de bruit.
Ils font plus de bruit. Oui. Et
normalement un peu ils font beaucoup de
bruit mais ils font plus et ils mangent
plus quelquefois pendant quelques jours.
Ils sont très intimidés par la mort.
et très affecté par la mort. Et dans la
nature, on a on a vu aussi des
situations où un chien pensé par exemple
casse son coup parce qu'il tombe d'une
d'une d'un arbre ou quelque chose comme
ça et qu'il est entouré par d'autres
anciens passés qui sont qui sont très
silencieux
et c'est comme si il ils comprennent que
c'est irréversible. situations qui qui
peuvent pas changer et cet individu est
à mort et alors ils peuvent avoir un un
conception de mort des autres. On dit ça
aussi des éléphants. On on dit ça aussi
d'autres grands singes
de mammifè marins.
Oui. Hein ?
Des dauphins.
Oui. Le dauphin. Le le le le le maire
dauphin qui garde leur petit et qui le
porte encore même si c'est mort. Euh
mais la question est-ce qu'ils
connaissent leur propre mort ? Est-ce
qu'ils ont un sens de mortalité ? Ça, on
sait pas. Et et moi j'ai jamais vu
évidence qui dit que ils ont cette
connaissance. Alors par exemple, il y a
une vidéo très fameux
euh où mon professeur Yan Vano rencontre
mam les ch pensé qui est en train de
mourir. Peut-être tu l'as vu.
Et c'est très émouvant comme vidéo parce
que lui le professeur, il va visiter
maman qui était presque 60 ans pour dire
au revoir parce que elle est en train de
mourir clairement.
Et c'est c'est une situation en plus
très
euh très difficile parce que normalement
on va jamais on entre jamais dans une
cage avec un chens adulte parce que
c'est très dangereux.
Les chers ils sont beaucoup plus forts
que nous et même maman qui est un
femelle
vieille, elle est encore plus forte que
cette professeur là.
Et mais il le fait quand même et les
gens ils ont vu ça comme si lui disait
au revoir à elle et elle pouvait dire au
revoir à lui. Mais moi je suis pas sûr
que elle savait qu'elle est en train de
mourir. Je suis pas sûr qu'elle a cette
conscience de mortalité que lui il
avait.
Et euh une autre chose qui est
intéressante dans cette vidéo, si si
vous le regardez, vous vous pouvez voir
le mam passé Yan von Hof, le professeur
euh parce que c'est vu j'étais vu par
200 millions de gens, je crois cette
vidéo. Euh une autre chose qui est
intéressante, c'est que je crois que
Mama a senti que lui, il était nerveux.
Il a entré dans une cage que normalement
il fait ferait jamais.
il a connu euh cette femelle pendant
très longtemps. Il il a osé de faire ça
mais je crois qu'il était nerveux et on
voit dans la vidéo que maman réit très
spontanément à son son approche mais
aussi elle essaie de le calmer calmer
comme le façon que femelle passé calme
un petit bébé fait comme ça
et c'est comme si elle sentit que il
était nerveux et pour le rassurer que
tout allait bien.
Ou
est-ce qu'ils sont conscients ? On va
prendre les grands singes Coco.
Est-ce qu'ils sont conscients que un
chat peut mourir ? Et si c'est le chat
du Gori, est-ce qu'il porte cette
tristesse ou c'est de
l'anthropromorphrisme
projeté ?
Oui, Coco et ses chats, moi je suis pas
sûr. Qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui se passait
là ? il donnait déjà peut-être
euh je sais pas comment elle était ass
attachée ou
je je je connais pas c cette situation
mais le gorille est coco il y a beaucoup
de situations manipulées
j'ai déjà dit que he
le cimetière des éléphants, on voit des
éléphants
prendre des os
est-ce que c'est pour le calcium ?
Est-ce que c'est pour rendre hommage ?
Est-ce que c'est une façon de porter le
deuil ou est-ce que c'est aussi
de l'anthropomorphisme appliqué ?
Non, il il y a beaucoup d'observations
de ça et qui retourne au aux hauses de
de leur connair qui qui qui était mort
et on pense que c'est continuation
d'attachement.
C'est souvent
le mort est som important pour les
individus qui sont attachés l'un à
l'autre.
Si euh
si si un sien pensé rencontre un autre
animal qui est mort, ça lui fait rien.
Mais si un individu qui connaît est
mort, et c'est pour nous aussi, c'est
pareil.
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a des
guerres. Oui,
parce queon se connaît pas.
Oui, peut-être. Oui.
Et si on se connaissait,
Ouais.
On éviterait de se tuer, non ?
Oui. Mais la guerre euh
qu'est-ce que c'est un français le PTSD
? C'est quoi
un trouble post-traumatique ? les
les raisons qu'on a ça, c'est parce que
tuer, c'est pas si facile pour l'homme.
C'est c'est
on pense ça pendant la guerre, les les
militaires sont bien sûr entraînés de
tuer, mais c'est pas une chose qui vient
naturellement au aux hommes, je crois.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on a de PT à se
dire. Ouais.
Revenons revenons au cimetière des
éléphants.
Ouais.
Ça se manifeste comment ? Est-ce que ça
a été étudié ? Est-ce que on écoute
leurs infrasons au moment où il touchent
les eaux par terre ? Est-ce que
Non, j'ai vu des photos et j'ai vu des
vidéos de ça, mais j'ai jamais entendu
qu'il y a des des études systématiques.
Est-ce qu'ils connaissent les éléphants
qui étaient morts là ? Moi je sais pas
qu'est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a des
études là-dessus ? Mais on sait que ça
arrive ça. Ça arrive assez souvent. Oui.
Il y a une vidéo très populaire sur
internet d'un Cornac. Vous connaissez
Cornac ?
de de le propriétaire de l'éléphant
fait semblant de se noyer
et son éléphant vient le chercher.
Ah ouais.
Ou le propriétaire de l'éléphant
se fait semblant de se faire attaquer
par quelqu'un d'autre et l'éléphant
vient le défendre.
Oh, c'est un peu dangereux ça ces yeux
là.
Ouais. [rires] Pour qui ? Pour
l'attaquant.
Oui oui oui oui. C'est dangereux. Ouais.
C'est quoi comme relation ça ? C'est une
relation
euh programmée ? C'est une relation
naturelle de défendre ses proches ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Oui, on peut faire cette expérience avec
toutes sortes d'animaux. Tu peux le
faire avec ton chien. Moi, j'essaie de
t'attaquer. On va voir qu'est-ce que ton
chien va fait. Il y a plein de chiens
qui vont te défendre, qui vont défendre
un enfant.
Euh les chiens pensés font font pareil.
Euh si tu travailles avec des jeunes,
c'est pensé parce que avec des adultes,
on va jamais Mais si tu travailles avec
des jeunes,
on va jamais quoi
avec des adultes ? Tu fais jamais un
contact direct parce qu'ils sont trop
forts. C'est c'est trop dangereux.
Personne fait ça. Mais avec les jeunes,
tu pe
j'étais souvent dans la situation où je
joue avec des jeunes jeunes je pensais.
Et oui, si euh par exemple, moi je fais
comme si j'attaque un jeune, il y a un
autre jeune qui son ami qui va venir le
défendre et oui, ça ça marche toujours.
C'est pas forcément préprogrammé, c'est
c'est réaction protective que on trouve
chez beaucoup animaux.
Question internet, j'en prends une au
passage. Est-ce que vous êtes végétarien
?
Non, je suis pas
du tout. Non,
non, je réduis, j'essaie de réduire euh
manger de la viande. Je mange surtout de
poisson en fait, plus que d'autres
viandes.
Mais
chez les biologistes, on trouve de
végétarien, je crois. Ça existe bien
sûr, mais on a tellement l'habitude de
voir des animaux qui mangent des animaux
qu'on n pas troublé par cette idée.
C'est plutôt ça qui qui me trouble.
C'est plutôt comment on traite les
animaux dans dans notre
industrie
agricultural industry.
[grognement] Le traitement des animaux
il faut qu'on change.
Vous connaissez cette phrase ?
On reconnaît le degré de d'évolution
d'une civilisation à sa façon de traiter
ses animaux.
Oui. Qui a dit ça ? Ça m'échappe. Je
sais que c'est la phrase qui est écrite
dans le manège du collège interarmé de
défense à Paris.
Ouais. Ouais.
C'est pas Gandi. Non, ça vaut pas de
Gandi.
Mais on a beaucoup de discussions
là-dessus en Hollande en ce moment.
comment traiter les animaux parce que
l'ande a beaucoup de de cochons et de
poules et tout ça et euh la façon qu'on
on se conduit avec ça n'est pas bien. Et
euh il y a bien sûr aussi une autre
solution qui est en train de venir,
c'est le la viande artificielle. c'est
c'est en train de développer et un jour
dans 10 ans ou 20 ans, je sais pas, un
jour ça va finir toute l'agriculture
animale, je pense.
Il y a un genre où il y a des genres
chez les chimpanzés ou chez les primates
ou chez les manchaud ou chez les
chevaux.
Est-ce que c'est une perception humaine
projetée sur notre société le genre ?
Est-ce que c'est
notre société religieuse qui a imposé ça
? Est-ce que c'est ça a été dans l'air
du temps pendant un temps et ça s'est
imposé contre nature ?
Est-ce qu'est-ce que vous avez écrit et
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la théorie
des genres ?
Euh moi, j'ai fait une distinction entre
les
le sexe biologique et les genres. Le
sexe biologique, c'est très clair, c'est
mâle, femelle. Il y a un petit groupe
entre les deux. C'est pas 100 % mais
c'est surtout mâle femelle. C'est défini
par les hormones, les chromosomes,
des génitaux, les organes génitaux, euh
des cerveaux.
C'est c'est le la distinction biologique
le genre moi je divise pas en mal femel
je divise en masculine féminin féminin
et toutes les formes entre les deux
c'est c'est beaucoup plus flexible qu'en
concept et c'est plutôt un concept
culturel c'est c'est l'expression de de
ton sexualité de l'expression dans de
dans la vie normale et c'est on apprend
ça on apprend d'être se comporter
comporter comme un homme ou apprend se
comporter comme une femme et euh c'est
beaucoup plus flexible comme concept et
puisque c'est culturel,
moi je crois pas que c'est limité aux
hommes parce que euh les primates par
exemple passé le Benobo, ils sont très
lents dans leur développement, ils sont
adultes quand ils ont 16 ans.
Comment dire le nursing ? Comment dire
ça ?
Le nursing le l'infirmière. Non le
Non,
le j'ai un trou de mémoire. Je vais vous
trouver ça tout de suite.
À la tâche, comment dire le
euh l'allaitement
allaitement
pendant 5 ans. Alors il sont très lents
dans leur développement. il il reste
bébé beaucoup plus beaucoup plus long
qu'on pense et euh ils apprennent
beaucoup de choses dans ce temps-là et
inclusif euh comment se comporter comme
un mâle et ou comme un female. Alors le
concept de des gens, on peut aussi
appliquer aux autres primates et c'est
un concept beaucoup plus flexible que le
sexe.
Mais il reste toujours lié. Les raisons
pourquoi on a une dualité de genre,
c'est parce que on a deux sexes. Il
reste toujours lié mais
c'est pas une connexion extrêmement
fort. Il y a des gens bien sûr qui
disent que le genre est purement
culturel. Moi je suis pas je peux pas
croire ça. Il y a rien qui est purement
culturel parce que nous on est des
animaux et notre culture transforme
notre comportement mais est toujours en
interaction avec nous comme animaux. Il
y a pas de choses purement culturelles,
il y a aussi pas de choses qui sont
purement biologiques parce que on est on
est peut-être né avec un certain corps
et avec certains gènes euh tout ça se
développe en interaction avec
l'environnement et il y a pas de des de
choses purement biologiques dans le
monde. Alors cette idée qu'il faut
choisir entre culture et biologie pour
comprendre le comportement humain ou
d'autres animaux,
je suis pas d'accord, il y a pas un
choix et c'est toujours une interaction
entre les deux.
C'est un mix entre
le côté pas je dirais pas atavique mais
le côté socioculturel et la génétique.
Oui, c'est toujours. C'est toujours les
deux.
Est-ce qu'il y a des chimpanzés étrangen
?
Ouais, ça c'est une question
intéressante. Il y a une grande
diversité des gens chez d'autres
primates et je crois que
mon discipline de primatologie, on n'
pas fait assez études là-dessus. On a
toujours regardé le mâ typique, le
femelle typique, on parle de ça, mais on
a toutes sortes d'autres variation et la
variabilité individuelle est partout
aussi au partout dans la nature. Il y a
pas deux arbres de même espace qui sont
pareils.
Dans la biologie, on connaît cette
variabilité.
Alors pour les genres euh j'ai décrit
dans mon livre un ch pensé qui s'appelle
Donna un femelle.
Comment il s'appelle le livre ?
Different déferante.
Déférant euh le genre vu par un
primatologue, je crois.
Et euh
dans mon livre, j'ai décrit Donna passé
female que j'ai connu depuis très petit.
Elle était elle était comme ça 3 ans et
elle voulait toujours faire le bagarre
avec moi ou avec des mâes. J'ai pensé
euh le mal alpha et ça c'est pas typique
pour les jeunes femelles. C'est c'est
plutôt les jeunes mâles qui veulent
faire ça. C'est pas les jeunes femelles
qui veulent ça c'est elle était déjà
différent à cette époque-là mais le mâ
acceptait ce comportement d'elle.
Normalement, il joue plus avec d'autres
jeunes mar et euh quand elle est devenue
plus plus vieille,
elle a développé les grands épaules et
le grand poils et les grandes têtes
comme si elle était mal. Elle avait
l'air de mal et elle aimait associé avec
le mal. Elle était toujours avec eux,
jouer avec eux, voyagait avec eux
et oui, c'est possible que je pouvais
pas demander son identité bien sûr, mais
c'est possible qu'elle s identifiait
comme un mâle plutôt qu'un femelle. Et
j'ai j'ai connu beaucoup d'autres
individus, des individus par exemple mâ
qui sont grands et forts mais qui
veulent pas jouer le les jeux politiques
de mal. Il ils veulent pas être en
compétition, ils veulent pas être mal
alpha, ils sont pas intéressés dans ce
genre de choses et il se comporte pas
comme un mal typique. Alors, il y a
toutes sortes d'individus bien sûr, il y
a aussi des individus qui sont plus
homosexuels que hétérosexuels. Ça existe
aussi. Le comportement homosexuel est
pas si rare chez les primates.
Comment c'est perçu par les autres ?
Oui, c'est ça qui ça qui est le plus
intéressant, c'est peut-être que
Don a était complètement intégré dans le
groupe. Elle était très bien accepté
et j'ai jamais vu de problèmes là-dessus
de par exemple les benob j'appelle
bisexuel parce que
chez le on peut pas faire la distinction
hétérosexuelle homosexuelle parce qu'
ils font l'amour eux avec tout le monde.
Et j'ai jamais vu que ça c'est un
problème et j'ai laissé penser aussi et
dans toutes toutes les primates et et
beaucoup d'autres espèces aussi. On voit
le comportement homosexuel c'est pas
c'est souvent un comportement de
minorité. C'est pas tout le monde qui
fait ça tout le temps, mais la minorité
fait ça et j'ai jamais vu que ça donne
le problème. Ouis.
Chez les bonobo dans la nature aussi.
Ouai. Ouais. Ouais. Ouais.
Chez les chimpanzés dans la nature
aussi. Oui, c'est le passé, c'est moins
commun mais ils font aussi. Oui.
Comment ça ça
la première fois que vous avez vu ça,
comment ça s'est analysé ? Comment vous
l'avez perçu ? Et comment vous regardez
le débat que nous dans notre société
humaine on peut avoir sur ça, sur les
différents genres ?
Oui.
Comment c'est perçu ? Comment vous
percevez-vous ? Moi, je vois ça
quelquefois comme un problème de
humanité, c'est que
euh on aime mettre des étiquettes sur t
tous les choses. Alors, par exemple, on
on a le L en anglais, on dit LGBTQ
community. Comment qu'est-ce que c'est
en français ? LGBTQ, c'est quoi ?
C'est pareil.
Ah, c'est pareil.
Et on rajoute un plus.
Mais tout ça, c'est des étiquettes.
On aime mettre des étiquettes sur tout
le monde et on est très normatif.
Euh toi tu es un homme, euh toi tu es
une femme, toi tu es hétérosexuel, toi
tu es on est très normatif et il faut se
comporter comme votre étiquette.
Et euh
attention si vous vous comportez pas
comme la bonne étiquette. Oui. Oui. Et
maintenant États-Unis, on a toute cette
discussion sur le transgenre, les gens
de transgenre comme si c'est un grand
problème. Moi, je crois pas c'est un
grand problème dans la société, mais
c'est c'est explodé comme un grand
problème maintenant. Et euh on a
tellement de normatif euh que là, on
peut apprendre quelque chose d'autre
primat, je crois, qu'ils acceptent les
autres comme ils sont.
Et moi je pense que les le les primates,
ils ont seulement de problèmes avec des
individus qui sont trop agressifs ou
trop violents. Là bien sûr, ça donne des
problèmes dans la société, mais
autrement ils sont pas très intéressés
de faire un crise là-dessus. Ouais.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me parler de la
coopération ?
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire de la
coopération des grands singes ? Est-ce
que le mal alpha
est mis à cette place de mal alpha parce
qu'il coopère mieux, parce qu'il apporte
plus de bonheur au groupe, de survie au
groupe, il connaît les points d'eau, il
connaît les meilleurs endroits où il y a
les meilleurs arbres avec les meilleurs
fruits, les plus sucrés. Et est-ce que
la coopération mène à la consommation de
drogues chez les chimpanzés ? Est-ce
qu'ils vont repérer un arbre où il y a
des fruits qui sont en train de macérer
avec de l'alcool à l'intérieur ? Ça
arrive, ça arrive. C'est ça s'appelle de
de drunken monkey hypothesis. [rires]
Euh ça arrive et et c'est pas seulement
les primates, hein, c'est aussi des
insectes quelque fois qui sont qui sont
euh
Oui. La fermentation et moi je suis pas
sûr qu' ils cherchent ça, mais je pense
que ça n'affecte sur eux et ça arrive
aussi chez les éléphants que ça que ça
se fait. Mais la coopération
euh on fait des expériences là-dessus.
Par exemple, on fait des expériences.
Est-ce qu'ils comprennent la coopération
? Par exemple,
tu donnes un test aussi pensé, il y a un
une grande boîte très lourd avec la
nourriture, il y a deux euh cordes
et
il faut deux sans pour le le le faire
venir euh plus près de eux pour manger
la nourriture.
Et euh ils vont prendre les cordes, ils
vont tirer, ils vont ils vont être très
bien coordinés.
Et alors la question certain moment
c'est est-ce qu'ils comprennent qu'ils
ont besoin l'un de l'autre ou c'est par
accident que tous les deux sont motivé
et accidentiellement comment dire euh
sans sans coordination
il ils font ça et la façon qu'on fait
cette expérience on fait un un
une clôture entre les deux
qui peuvent plus le se voir. Alors ils
onent encore le corde. Les cordes sont
là
peuvent s'entendre. Ils peuvent
s'entendre, ils ont des cordes. La
nourriture est là, pour le reste, la
situation pareil, mais ils peuvent pas
se voir là, ils peuvent plus le faire.
Et ça veut dire que la coord des nations
est vrai. Et on a fait c ce genre
d'expérience avec des oiseaux, avec des
éléphants, avec toutes sortes espèces.
C'est pas tous les espèces qui
comprennent la la coopération. C'est pas
tout ce qu'il comprennent.
Et euh les chens pensé oui, il ils ont
cette connaissance. Oui.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe sur un territoire
de chimpanzé dans la nature quand les
ressources se rarifient ?
Ouais, ça c'est intéressant, c'est que
autrefois
les gens pensaient que si ça arrive, par
exemple, il y a un dr, comment dire euh
drive,
sécheresse
euh ou une autre catastrophe,
on pensait que peut-être ça donnerait
plus de compétition très darwiniens. Ils
vont se tuer entre eux
ou ils vont aller tuer les autres
ou des autres. Oui, mais en fait c'est
pas ça qui arrive.
On a vu de ce serain
et euh il y a des études qui étaient
faites sur le baboin et en fait il ils
voyagent moins, ils ont moins
d'agression entre eux et on pense
maintenant parce que après on a toujours
l'explication pour tout on pense
maintenant c'est parce qu' ils veulent
conserver l'énergie parce
d'énergie
de l'énergie
oui
il ils peuvent Quand quand j'avais des
nais dans cette situation là,
une autre situation quand quand le COVID
est venu en Toscanie et à New York,
j'ai j'ai vu des articles qui qui
disaient "Bien sûr, les gens vont vont
voir plus de conflict parce qu' il faut
qu'ils restent à la maison, ils peuvent
plus sortir.
Ils sont ils ont peur des autres parce
que à cause de des virus et tout ça, il
va avoir plus de conflit entre les gens.
Mais en fait, il y avait beaucoup de
coopération au debout. Au début, il y
avait en Toscanie et à New York, il y
avait un un coopération élevée chez les
gens dans cette situation d'adversité.
Et euh on sous-estime, je crois que la
adversité peut en fait mettre les gens
ensemble ou les animaux ensemble et
réduire ce genre de compétition.
Comment ça s'est passé dans les dans les
eaux ou dans vos lieux d'étude où il y
avait des primates
avec le Covid ?
[raclement de gorge]
Ils ont subi un confinement. Les
soignants euh se sont confinés avec
au début les soignants bien sûr avait
toujours de masque parce que le Covid
était très dangereux pour d'autres
primates aussi.
Et je je me souviens que les sanctuaires
par exemple avec le Benobo de l'ola,
les sanctuaires ils ont complètement
fermés. Ils ont pas euh il y avait pas
de visiteurs qui pouvaient venir
et les gens qui prennent soin de des
jeunes Benobo euh il restaient là, ils
sortaient pas d'aller dans leur village,
il restait dans le sanctuaire. Alors les
eaux, ils étaient très prudents avec les
animaux
et c'est je suis pas sûr qu'ils ont pris
des vaccin pour les grands singes. Mais
euh il y en a qui ont fait ça, je suis
sûr, mais je suis pas sûr que tout le
monde a fait ça.
Question internet,
je vais la poser telle qu'elle a été
posée. Je suis fasciné. Si les
chimpanzés défendent les individus de
leur groupe, peut-on alors parler de
religion, de nation chimpanzé ?
religion
et nation de s passé
s'ils défendent leurs proches
il y a plein des animaux qui font ça
défendre leurs proches
donc c'est une religion universelle de
défendre ses proches
on dit pas forcément c'est religion non
il y a plein des animaux qui défendent
leurs proches et tout toute la mère mam
fière il défendent leurs petit ou
c'est pour que le groupe soit plus
nombreux c'est pour mieux survivre
C'est c'est pourquoi
oui [grognement] dans dans la nature
tout est basé sur la reproduction
toute la loi de évolution c'est est-ce
qu'on on reproduit ou on reproduit pas
ça c'est important
je peux vous couper
ou
le chimpansé trangenre que vous avez pu
étudier
oui
en terme de stimuli sexuel qu'il
renvoyait aux autres et inversement
comment ça se passait
comment ça
est-ce qu'il était considéré comme un un
mâle Il se comportait sexuellement comme
un mâle avec les femelles ou est-ce que
les mâles considéraitent comme une
femelle et voulait s'accoupler avec ou
la distance, le physique, la carrure,
l'attitude supprimait ce type de de
d'interaction.
Elle est un femelle, moi je appelle
asexuel. Elle était pas intéressée dans
les relations sexuelles.
Elle était sans doute aussi
hormonalement un peu différente d'autres
femelles. Différente.
Différente. Oui. Et elle a jamais eu de
bébé par exemple les mâ étaient pas
intéressés en elle sexuellement. Elle
était pas intéressée dans de femelles ou
ou des mâles sexuellement. Alors je
considère comme asexuel. Oui.
Désolé de vous avoir coupé. [rires]
Oui.
Donc revenons à à la à la nation
chimpanzée.
Oui.
Est-ce que le fait de défendre c'est
pour faire perdurer son patrimoine
génétique ? Vous étiez en train de nous
expliquer ? Oui, en général euh
le mal la reproduction des mals est liée
à leur position dans le
et sils sont de haute une haute
position, ils ont plus d'accès aux
femelles et c'est pour ça que les mâles,
ils font des compétitions là-dessus et
essaie d'être le mâle alpha.
Euh on pense ça c'est le théorie euh
pour les femelles.
Le success
euh euh de reproduction est lié à
défendre leurs petits. Les nourrir bien
sûr, les porter, les protéger,
les défendre
et s'ils font pas ça, ils vont perdre
leurs petits et c'est pas bien pour leur
reproduction. Alors les les biologues en
général on a des ce genre de explication
pour le comportement c'est c'est un
service de reproduction parce que ceux
qui sont bien là-dedans, ceux qui
transmettent leur gène dans la prochaine
génération.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me parler de
l'équité, de moralité
et des des manifestations de Wall Street
?
Quelle manifestation
de de Wall Street ? Ah oui,
nous on a fait des expériences sur les
équités.
J'ai cru que vous alliez me dire vous
avez fait des expériences sur des
traders. Ouais, c'est un peu ça en fait.
C'est un peu ça parce que on avait
découvert
une étudiante à moi qui s'appelle Sarah
Brosnan qui est maintenant professeur
qui et moi on avait découvert par hasard
que le singe capin qu'on c'est des
petits singes comme ça mais c'est
extrêmement intelligent comme primate
que le singe capin qu'on testait souvent
en père parce que comment dire
en binô
hein
en binô par père
il y a ensemble
Au lieu de individuellement,
on faisait beaucoup de tests comme ça.
On remarquait que les individus sont
très sensible à qu'est-ce que l'autre
reçoit. Imagine que nous on fait les
tests ensemble et toi tu reçois beaucoup
plus de récompenses que moi, de bonnes
récompenses. Moi, je suis pas je suis
pas très bien là-dedans.
Ça ça m'affecte moi. Ça ça me donne des
frustrations.
Ça t'énerve ?
Ça m'énerve. Ouai. Et en en américain,
on dit un pist off. Ouais. Alors euh on
a remarqué ça et on a décidé de faire
une expérience là-dessus par faire euh
deux singes un à côté de l'autre faire
exactement la même tâche pour laquelle
il pouvait avoir de nourriture
euh mais de donner de meilleur
nourriture à un et pas si bien
nourriture à l'autre.
Si tu donnes tous les deux singes les
petits morceaux de concombre, ils sont
très contents. Ils le font 25 fois, il y
a pas de problème.
Si tu donnes l'autre de de raisin, lui
reçoit encore de de concombre. Lui, il
reçoit de raisins. Et les raisins sont
beaucoup mieux que le concombre. Ils
savent ça, ils sentent ça aussi.
Là, celui-ci qui reçoit des concombres
devient agité, devient frustré. veut
plus faire la tâche même si le comcom
bien mais pas quand lui il reçoit de des
raisins. C'est comme ça qu'on a commencé
des des expériences sur le fairness avec
les capins d'abord et on on dit que ils
ont sens sense sense of sense of
fairness
d'équité
équité. Oui. Et après, on a fait la même
chose avec des siens pensés qui sont
beaucoup plus intelligents que le petit
singe. Et les siens pensés vont plus
loin. Eux, quelquefois celui-ci qui
reçoit le raisin peut refuser le raisin
jusque le moment que l'autre reçoit
aussi le raisin. Alors, ils ont un sens
de équité qui est beaucoup plus
développé, beaucoup plus humain.
Chez les humains, pas tout le monde fait
ça en fait. [rires]
pas tout le monde si idéalistique mais
euh on a fait cette expérience là et
j'ai utilisé ça souvent comme un un
exemple de moi je crois que la moralité
humain est basée sur les émotions
primates et l'empathie un exemple
le sens de équité un exemple le suivre
des règles de société c'est un exemple
il y a beaucoup d'exemples où on peut
voir que la moralité c'est pas une
invention de nous mais il y a certaines
équivalence avec le comportement de
primate.
Vous parliez d'intelligence différente
entre les capucins et les chimpanzés.
C'est quoi l'intelligence ?
Ouais, l'intelligence c'est la capacité
de trouver des solutions
surtout pour le problème que tu n'as pas
vu avant. T'as pas vu venir ?
Oui. Que que tu n'as pas beaucoup
d'expérience avec avant
de nouvelles situation
et les chiens passés sont très bien
là-dedans. L'expérience classique
c'est fait il y a il y a 100 ans où on
met un banane à très haute
sur le plafond,
on donne les chiens pensés des boîtes et
des
sticks, comment dire ? des bâtons,
des bâtons
et on on leur apprend rien mais on le
met dans cette situationlà
et euh certaines chînes pensées
intelligents euh après euh nombre de
minutes et il ils mettent ça ensemble il
ils mettent les les poes l'un sur
l'autre, ils prendent le bâton et ils
prennent les banana
dans ce cas-là ils ont trouvé une
solution sur un problème qu'ils ont
jamais a rencontré avant, même s'ils ont
peu d'expérience avec toutes les trois
choses, mais pas la combinaison. Et ça
ça c'est un exemple d'intelligence, je
crois.
Ouais.
C'est que nous avec le réchauffement
climatique, si on coopère pas, ça veut
dire qu'on est très stupide.
Il dit ça dans l'informatique,
non ? Si avec le réchauffement
climatique, nous l'humanité nous ne
coopérons pas. Infin, ça veut dire qu'on
est très stupide. Oui oui, c'est c'est
c'est dommage que on n'est pas capable
de sortir
de notre comment dire short termining.
La façon court termiste de penser. Oui.
Oui.
Est-ce qu'il y a de la cupidité chez les
prim chez les primates
qui se sentent coupable
dans la cupidité ?
Comment on dit en anglais ?
Non, c'est radin grid. Euh people, les
gens qui se comportent pour toujours
avoir tout. Est-ce qu'il y a il y a ça
chez les primates ?
Greediness.
Oui. Greediness.
Oui. Euh, ils ont pas une accumulation
de possession comme nous on a
ils sont seulement intéressés dans le
qu'est-ce qui mange en ce moment
et où où le où les le les partenaires
sexuels qu'ils ont en ce moment,
ils ont pas une accumulation, ils ont
pas un maison où ils accumulent des des
choses comme nous on fait. Mais euh je
crois que notre espèce un peu spécial
là-dedans. Ouais.
Est-ce que vous avez vu le film Instinct
avec Anthony Hopkins ?
Non, j'ai pas vu.
C'est un primatologue qui assiste à une
tuerie dans le groupe de singes dans
lequel il avait été accepté.
Ah ! et il se venge en tapant un
braconnier
et un des braconniers le met en joue et
un grand le dos le dos gris, le dos
argenté vient pour le défendre et se
fait tuer. Et le primatologue termine
dans un asile de fou.
Oh,
je vous le conseille, c'est pas mal.
Non, j'ai pas vu ça. Non,
j'ai j'ai vu le film de planète des de
planète des singes.
Planète des singes et et j'ai vu
plusieurs et j'ai
conseillante sur une je crois. Et euh
j'ai un problème avec ce film là. Il y a
une chose que je trouve très positif,
c'est qu'on fait ce genre de film
maintenant sans sans vrai singe. Les
singes sont animés. Autrefois
il y avait beaucoup de des choses à
Hollywood où où il mettent des vrais
gori et de vrais orangoutang. Moi je
suis j'étais pas d'accord. Alors ça
c'est les choses positives sur le
planète de Saint mais les choses
négatives c'est que c'est toujours des
guerres entre mal. On voit très peu de
femelles, on voit très peu de jeunes, on
voit pas la vie normale des des des
primates, on va surtout des mal avec des
grandes armes qui qui se battent entre
eux. Oui, c'est très violent.
Est-ce que vous voulez aborder un sujet
avec nous en particulier ? Est-ce que
vous voulez pas nous parler de quelque
chose en particulier ? Vous voulez
aborder un sujet ? Vous avez un sujet
qui vous tient à cœur ?
Il y a beaucoup de sujets qui sont très
importants pour ma comparon, pour
l'empathie. On peut parler de ça, de de
où ça vient et qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Oui.
Allez-y. [rires] Ça vient d'où
l'empathie ?
Oui, euh
l'empathie c'est être sensible aux
émotions des autres et être sensible aux
situations d'autres et à la fin
peut-être aussi aider l'autre. Ouais,
mais c'est aider l'autre, c'est pas la
définition de empathie. L'empathie,
c'est que ton sensibilité.
Et euh quand moi j'ai commencé de parler
de empathie chez des animaux dans les
années
90 environ,
les gens étaient très très contre. Les
gens voulaient pas entendre ça.
C'est qui les gens ?
Les académiques
surtout. Les philosophes
Oui, des gens parce que les gens dans la
rue ils ont leurs chiens. Si tu dis il y
a des empathies si les animaux ils
disent mon chien il fait ça, mon chien
fait ça. Mais les académiques, ils ont
des définitions qui exclusaient des
animaux.
Et c'est parce que à l'époque dans la
psychologie, l'empathie était toujours
définie comme une chose d'imagination.
Moi je je m'imagine ta situation.
Je projette mes émotions.
Oui, je me projette dans ta situation.
Et et il peuvent il pouvait pas croire
qu'un animal pouvait faire ça. Et alors
pour ça, il y avait c'était la fin de la
discussion.
Mais euh dans la même époque chez les
gens, on a trouvé que l'empathie est
involontaire automatique.
C'est un un scientifique en Suède qui
est sur des écrans de ordinateur, il a
montré des expressions faciales de
tristesse ou de de gailleté
aux gens
et il a mesuré dans leurs muscles.
Est-ce qu'ils imitaient les expressions
oui ou non ? Quelque fois très très
petit. Tu vois par exemple
musculaire.
Oui. Tu vois par par exemple quelqu'un
rire. Toi tu ris pas mais tes muscles
qui font qui te font rire sont déjà
activés.
Alors, il a montré ce visage là, les
expressions subliminales. Ça veut dire
pendant je crois une vingta de secondes,
très très peu. Les gens avaient
l'impression qu'ils étaient en train de
regarder des paysages et des maisons et
de voitures et des choses comme ça. Mais
lui, il montre des des visages de facial
là-dedans. Les gens étaient très
affectés. Alors, si tu vois beaucoup de
visages tristes, tu deviens triste. Tu
vois beaucoup de visages gai, tu deviens
gai. Même si tu n'es pas conscient que
tu vu le visage, alors lui conclu
l'empathie parce que c'est une forme
d'empathie là euh automatique et
involontaire. Et là les les
scientifiques, les psychologues, ils ont
commencé à penser défarment sur leur
empathie et 10 ans plus tard, il
commença à accepter que peut-être les
animaux aussi, ils ont d'empathie.
Maintenant, on a beaucoup d'expériences
là-dessus. Ils font des expériences sur
l'empathie. C'est les rodens, comment
dire ?
Les rougeurs. Les rats,
Oui. Les rats, des souris. Oui.
Les écureuils.
Oui, on oui, on fait des des recherches
d'empathie de chiens surtout. Il y a
beaucoup de recherche sur le chien. Et
et ça marche environ pareil que chez
nous. Oxytocine fait partie de de
la production d'oxytocine.
Oui, ça fait partie de tout ça. Et euh
je pense que le processus est très
pareil chez toute la mamère. Oui.
Est-ce que vous croyez en Dieu ? Est-ce
que vous avez un ami imaginaire ? H non,
je suis pas très croyant. J'ai j'ai créé
un livre qui s'appelle le Bonobo and the
Atheist. Euh les Bonobo et les
athéistes.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Et c'était sur euh est-ce
qu'on a besoin de religion pour être
morale ?
Parce que je pense que la religion peut
aider, je peux aussi être le contraire,
mais la religion peut aider par donner
des justifications pour certains
comportements chez l'homme,
mais la moralité est beaucoup plus vieux
que la religion. notre religion qu'on a
maintenant qui a 2000 ans ou 3000 ans
euh euh ça suffit pas pour expliquer la
moralité chez chez l'humain. Oui.
Qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui pourrait
l'expliquer ?
Moi je pense que c'est ce je de
tendances que j'ai dit comme le
l'empathie, le sens de équité, le le
sens de suivre de de de règles sociales.
Moi je crois que on a des capacités qui
sont intégrées dans le système moraux.
Euh les systèmes moraux sont plus
complexes que ça. C'est plus que ça.
Mais je crois pas que la religion peut
expliquer que on est comme ça.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand on prend un
chimpanzé ?
et qu'on le met en en
privation sensorielle ou privation
sociale, est-ce qu'il développe des
troubles du comportement ? Est-ce qu'il
devient plus agressif ? Est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Est-ce que ça
fait comme avec l'homme ?
Ouais, ça c'est pas bien parce que c'est
à fait Harry Harl, c'est un primatologue
qui enlevait des bébés de leur mère, le
bébé Ris Ris.
et il a fait toute recherche et c'est
pas seulement lui, il y a beaucoup
d'autres qui ont fait cette recherche
qui enlevaient des bébés et il mettent
en isolation et il regarde quelques
années plus tard comment est leur
comportement et c'est pas bien c'est
très mal maladaptif
et euh c'est très c'est très dur de leur
changer après.
Oui, c'était fait c'était fait tout ça.
Est-ce que vous voyez des similitudes
sur notre société telle qu'elle se
développe ? [soupir]
On n plus vraiment d'interaction avec
les autres.
On est déconnecté de notre biotop.
Notre fenêtre sur les étoiles
se résume à la largeur d'une rue.
Oui, mais on a beaucoup de contacts
quand même. Par exemple,
dans les médias sociaux,
on a beaucoup de contact. On a beaucoup
de contact euh directement. En fait,
c'est intéressant avec le Covid.
On se on s'en rend compte que on est des
primates, on a besoin de contact
physique, on a besoin de voir des gens
de prê le sentir. On on sous-estime
toujours le sentir au faction.
Euh
on a vraiment des primates, on a besoin
de C'est pour ça que tout le monde était
si content que la crise Covid était
finie parce que
elle est finie chez vous mais pas chez
vous. Oui, il est complè pas
complètement fini mais on a beaucoup
plus de on était content d'avoir contact
après un période de déprivation.
Oui.
Question internet. Que pensent-il des
arguments de freud sur la naissance de
la culture ?
H
je suis pas très freudien.
Je veux dire Freud, il pensait que on
est né avec des instincts basales
négatif
assez destructif
mais que la civilisation est nécessaire
de supprimer ça et de garder ça dans
leur place
et et les civilisation fait possible
qu'on a une société bien organisée.
C'est un peu le même le même théorie. On
va citer Steve Pinker. Steve Pinker a la
même un peu la même idée. La
civilisation humaine, c'est ça qui fait
qu'on on se comporte mieux entre nous.
Je trouve ça toujours bizarre. En plus
dans ce théorie là, souvent c'est l'idée
que la civilisation de occidental est
supérieure à tous les autres. Les autres
gens malheureusement ils ont pas une
civilisation comme ça. Il y a un élément
raciste là-dedans quelquefois.
[grognement]
Et euh
non, moi je crois pas que la
civilisation c'est une extension de nous
de nous comme espèce.
C'est pas un un chose indépendant qui
fait que on peut se contrôler. Mais
c'est ça l'idée Fredy. Oui.
Question internet. Comment monsieur de
Walt de Wall s'explique-t-il
l'immoralité de nos sociétés alors que
la moralité semble inée à notre espèce ?
Qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que la première
partie des questions ?
Comment s'explique-t-il l'immoralité
de nos sociétés alors que la moralité
semble inée à notre espèce ?
Oui, mais la moralité n'est pas innée
dans le sens que la biologie donne des
lois de moralité. Je crois pas que c'est
si simple que ça.
La biologie donne des capacités comme
être sociable, être empathique, avoir
des connexions avec d'autres, de
coopération avec d'autres.
La biologie fait possible tout ce genre
d'interaction.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'on décide ? Est moral
ou pas moral dans la société
est décidé par la société. C'est pour ça
que c'est variable. ces variables dans
le temps parce que maintenant on a
d'autres règles de moralité qu'il y a
500 ans. Alors ça varie dans le temps,
ça varie de pays de à pays. Il y a des
cultures qui sont très différentes l'un
à l'autre. Et la moralité n'est pas
dictée par la biologie mais c'est fait
possible par la biologie. Ouais.
Question internet. Peut-il nous parler
de l'humour chez les animaux ?
Ouais. observer ? Peut-on le mesurer ?
Comment ? Chez quelles espèces le
trouve-t-on ou la trouve-ton ? C'est un
bon sujet parce que
euh j'ai j'ai vu des cas, il y a pas de
recherche là-dessus, il y a pas de
bonnes recherches là-dessus, mais j'ai
vu des cas qui suggèrent très forcément
un sens d'humour. Par exemple,
[rires]
par exemple, les les chosés, ils
rigolent comme nous. Si si tu
chatouilles un jeune chensé
et il fait une expression comme rire, il
fait de bruit comme rire comme [rires]
ce genre de bruit. Il fait
"Vous imitez très très bien mon rire."
Oui. Oui. Alors ils ont un un une façon
de rire.
Souvent c'est utilisé dans le jeu leur
jeu quand ils se chatouillent ou c'est
ils sautent l'un sur le sur l'autre.
Mais quelquefois
arrive aussi dans des situations
situations que nous on trouve
humoristique. Par exemple, tu peux avoir
un un mâle alpha
qui est chassé qui est en jeu et en
train de jouer avec un petit bébé, il
est chassé par un bébé
et le bébé est très petit et lui il a
une grande expression de rire comme siil
trouve ça extrêmement drôle que ce petit
est en train de lui chasser un pense
pense de gagner peut-être.
Euh où on peut avoir une situation,
j'avais une fois un collègue qui avait
mis un masque de panthère sur son
visage. Il s'est caché dans le dans la
brousse et les chiens passés étaient son
sur une grande île loin et il se
montrait avec son masque de panthère et
le ch passé était était tu tu parlais
des de jeté des excréments. C'est ça
qu'ils étaient en train de faire. Il il
réagissait très agressivement contre le
prédateur. Et après avoir fait ça cinq
fois, il a fait ça cinq fois. Le 5ème
fois il il était debout, il enlevait son
masque et plusieurs simpens ils ont fait
cette visage de rire comme s'ils aient
trouvé ça assez drôle parce qu'ils
connaissent le mec et il trouvaient ça
assez drôle qu'il est qu'il a fait comme
s'il était un panthère. Il y a plus
d'exemples comme ça que il y a
incongruité dans la réalité et c'est ça
en fait la base de sens d'humour, je
crois que on détecte une incongruité, on
trouve ça assez drôle. Oui.
Merci de vous exprimer en français avec
un français, je vais pas dire parfait
mais ciselé. Est-ce que vous avez trois
livres à conseiller à notre communauté ?
Trois livres. Et je vais je vais vous
demander de nous conseiller trois livres
que vous avez écrit après.
Vous voulez dire des livres sur des
primates ou des animaux ?
Des livres qui ont compté dans votre
vie.
Ah oui.
Euh
moi j'étais très affecté mais je
conseille pas ça comme livre maintenant
par le livre de Mor qui s'appelle de
Naked ape. Que c'est quoi le Naked ape ?
dans les le
dans les années 60, c'est c'était un des
premiers livres populaires sur le comp
le sing à de Nick apeur
le singe nu.
Oui.
Mais ce ce livre maintenant peut-être
c'est un peu old fashioned ce genre de
livre.
Euh, il y a des livres sur le le
darminisme qui qui sont intéressants. Et
par exemple, je parle dans mon livre de
sur le genre sur la sexualité féminin.
Il y a maintenant un joli livre
là-dessus qui s'appelle [__] en anglais
qui veut dire en français.
C'est [__] c'est pas positif.
Non, non, je sais pas qu'est-ce que
c'est en français.
Oui, d'accord. [rires]
C'est la plage ou c'est [__] ? Non non,
c'est pas [__] Non,
non. Bach
[__] [__] c'est plutôt
[__]
Oui. H je sais pas qu'est-ce que
[grognement]
c'est c'est un chien un femelle chien.
Ah, une chienne.
Une chienne. Oui.
Ouais. Mais il faut me demander ça une
autre fois. Le
le livre. un 3è livre à conseiller. On
vous demande la prochaine fois vous avez
un troisème livre à nous conseiller ?
Je sais pas. Non non.
Est-ce que vous avez un
Il faut tu trouves grave ? Il faut que
je pas toilette.
Ah gen on a on a fini dans une minute.
Oui oui oui. OK.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Quelque chose d'impérissable ? Ben,
c'est toujours la même chose. Il faut
suivre tes idées, il faut suivre tes
intéresses parce que je vois trop de
étudiants qui qui font des études pour
soit faire des d'argent, soit parce que
leurs parents veulent quelque chose.
Mais je trouve qu'il faut suivre leur
idée. France de Val. Merci
de rien.
[musique]